hello everyone and welcome to the final
pair we'll be covering from the
quarterfinals of this year's video World
Cup it is a game between Arjun edegasi
and pragnananda and uh if you've if
you've watched the match you know what
I'm talking about this was uh such a
nail biter I don't we've seen such
action in defeated World Cup so far uh
it actually took nine games for the
winner of this match to be decided so I
will tell you that and I will show you
two games from this match that I thought
there were very very interesting so
let's dive straight into it and see who
will qualify for the semi-finals of
defeated World Cup uh and uh well if
Magnus will not play in the candidates
tournament this could also be a direct
ticket to the candidates tournament for
whoever wins this match that being said
let's check it out Arjun has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to E4 now
this is uh from the faster rapid section
the 25 minute rapid games both ended in
a draw and this is the first game of the
10 minute rapid section game so E5 uh E4
E5 we have D4 that Arjun goes for the
center game uh ecaptor on D4 and now
Queen captures on D4 I thought it'd be
really cool if you went for C3 but it's
uh okay it's a very serious game so
Knight to C6 with Queen to E3 and Knight
to F6 uh we have Bishop to D2 uh Bishop
to E7 and now Pawn to C for going for
this marozzi type structure uh holding
um uh on that D5 Square very tight we
have Knight to G4 and believe it or not
this is already a new move by Prague so
now as of move six we have a completely
new game uh we have Queen back to E2 and
now Pawn to D6 we have Knight to C3 and
now Bishop to H4 uh Prague puts pressure
on that F2 pawn and the origin just
kicks it away G3 Bishop to F6 and now
Pawn to H3 kicks away the Knight with
Knight G to E5 and now uh Castle's Queen
side we have Knights the D4 uh putting
pressure on the queen here and queen to
E3 we have Pawn to C5 cementing that
Knight on D4 and Knight to D5 an
excellent Square for arjun's Knight with
Bishop d 6 and now Pawn the F4 kicking
the Knight away from E5 Knight E back to
C6 and now Bishop to C3 putting pressure
on the D4 Knight we have castles and now
Knight captures on F6 so eliminating one
of the Defenders and also a potential
attacker before uh continuing to advance
those King side pawns as you will have
King castles on opposite sides of the
board so yeah it does make sense to push
those spawns we have Queen captures now
Knight to F3 we have Queen back D7 and
Bishop captures on D4 we have C capture
Sunday for Knight captures Knight
captures and queen captures on D4 and we
end this a very nice variation with
Arjun if you counted the pawns is up a
pawn but it does seem like Prague is
getting uh a lot for the position uh and
he plays Pawn to B5 which you really
can't accept I mean you could but then
if C captures on B5 uh Bishop captures
an A2 now the B1 square is covered Rook
Rook is coming to see it with check and
you you could even play this I mean it's
not lost or anything let's say Bishop to
D3 Rook have to see it with Chair King
can come to D2 to E3 and the King will
be very safe on E3 but I mean if you
don't have to play this maybe skip it so
instead we have King to B1 and now
Bishop captures on C4 we have Bishop
captures B captors and queen captures
and C for an extra opponent is uh
perfectly fine for Arjun he doesn't want
to push it we have Rook the H to sorry
Pawn to A5 we have Rook to H2 and now
Pawn to A4 Arjun stops further
advancement of the pawn V upon to A3 and
now Rook F the C8 attacks the queen
queen to D3 and now Pawn to H6 and now
you could start pushing right away but
first we have rooked the C2 offering a
rook trade and Prague trades Rooks we
have Rook captures Queen captures and
now Queen to E6 putting pressure on that
H3 Pawn so G4 and now Queen to F6 uh we
have pawned the F5 as the F4 Pawn was
hanging and now Rook the B8 and if you
look at this position you're probably be
thinking all right Prague really made
Arjun put his pawns on weird squares
because now none of the pawns can really
Advance forward the queen paralyzes that
and he has constant pressure against the
B2 Pawn obviously he is very much
winning here believe it or not this is a
very close to Lost for Prague because
Arjun just plays uh first he plays King
A2 and now I have to Rook the B5 he just
plays Rook to D2 and now the queen can
move the B2 Pawn is defended and if you
look at the position if Prague doesn't
really have anything then Arjun is just
up a pawn so here we have Rook to B3 and
now Rook to D3 offering a rook trade and
preparing Rook to C3 to go for Rook to
C8 with check Prague of course declines
this and now Rook the C3 we have Queen
to D4 and now Queen to D3 Arjun very
happy with a trade with his extra Pawn
uh Queen to E5 Prague of course does not
want to trade queens and now Queen to C4
with uh Queen to H uh Queen to H2
putting again pressure on that B2 pawn
and out Rook to see through defending
giving up the H3 Pawn for the A4 Pawn so
we have Queen captures on H3 Queen
captures an A4 Arjun eliminates that
annoying A4 pawn and now we have Rook to
B8 of course capturing on G4 is out of
the question if you do this just Queen
T8 with checking H7 and Rook to C8 will
in turn uh the black gets checkmated so
after Queen captures an A4 we have Rogue
back to B8 you have to defend along the
second Rank and now we have Rook the C7
uh nicely I'll put in the rook and the
seventh rank uh evolving it into a pig
and preparing Queen to C4 to go after
that F7 Pawn so Queen captures in G4
this is now possible with Queen to C4
and now Rook to f8 product defends the
F7 pawn and now Arjun starts advancing
his past a pawn so Pawn to A4 but Prague
also has a past H Pawn we have Ponte H5
A5 we have Pawn to H for A6 and now uh
objectively Prague is dead lost here
because it's just very easy to you know
push the pawn to A7 trade Rooks and
promote this Pawn to a queen but he
plays this weird move on to D5 and now
what can Arjun do here well obviously he
has to capture it but how to capture it
uh you're not gonna capture with the
pawn because then Prague trades queens
and then he might have some surviving
chances so Arjun okay captures with the
with the queen and what's the idea
behind this weird Pawn sacrifice and
both of them were incredibly low on time
here so it was just uh I mean if you
have the chance to watch the matches
live it will will be an absolute
Thriller for you Brock finds Queen to
eat you and now he wants queen captures
on A6 or even if Ponte A7 he wants to go
for this queen to A6 check and now it's
basically a draw King to B1 You're Gonna
Play Queen to F1 check and if Rook to C1
then you're gonna play Queen to A6 and
so on with the a square A8 Square being
nicely defended uh maybe not uh you know
an iron clad draw but you you definitely
have fighting chances however Arjun
played Queen to C4 he thought his
Advantage was already so vast that he
can just trade Queens but that's the one
thing he couldn't do and now Prague
trades characters captures and plays a
rook to A8 how do you defend the pawn
well the problem is if you play Rook C6
then H3
and now if Pawn to B4 uh let's say you
want to play Pawn to B5 already Rook
captures and H6 settles the game Rook
captures and now H2 and there is no Rook
H6 to stop the pawn from promoting so be
one of the rare uh cases where B4 does
not win you the game uh or rather uh it
it in that line that we've shown after
H3 But Here pawn to B4 right away
without advancing uh uh uh the pawn or
going Rook to C6 is uh the best move in
the position so of course Arjun plays it
Rook campus and A6 with check King the
B3 and now Pawn to H3 we have Pawn to B5
Arjun has another pass Pawn now it's a
past B Pawn and Rook the H6 proc puts
the Rook behind the pass Pawn uh we have
Rook to see it with check King to H7 and
now Rook back to C1 your Rook has to be
ready to stop the pawn uh we have Pawn
to G5 now Prague wants another pass Pawn
we have capture sampa song captures and
now Pawn to B6 with Pawn to G5 now now
making the idea of B7 uh well uh just uh
bad because Rook the B6 check will pick
up the pawn so instead after G5 Rook the
C7 check by out of June we have King to
G8 and now Rook the C8 with check King
F7 Rook the C7 checking to E8 and now
Pawn to B7 threatening mate in one but
now Rook the B6 with check we have King
to C4 and now uh how do you play this
well if you play Ponte H2 and this is
the move you really want to play it
doesn't work because if H2 then Rook to
H7 the pawn will not be promoting
anytime soon so instead proc plays Pawn
to G4 which is the only winning move in
the position but of course you have to
realize why Rook to H7 by Arjun and now
there is only one move that wins the
game but I'm sure you guys see it just
in case you you can't feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only
winning move for Prague while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh tricky move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Rook captures sorry Rook captures
some B7 uh so a big congratulations on
sporting that I'm sure you guys are
studying the end game very hard every
day you know no breakfast before before
50 end games are sold Rook captures on
B7 Rook captures and now of course spawn
to H2 and the pawns are now Unstoppable
Rook to H7 was played and now comes on
to G3 we have King to D5 and now Pawn to
G2 of course you have to allow the the
queening of the pawn Rook captures on H2
and now G1 Queen we have rooked the B2
and now you will try to to hold this to
a draw but of course it is a very much a
known winning position we have Queen to
G8 with check now the white team will
have to go after the white rook and he
will have to give up the pawn on e4 so
King to C5 with Queen to G5 with
checking the C4 Queen to C1 with check
and now King to B3 Queen to E3 would
check this wins upon so this is the
first way you know phase of the plan
second phase will of course be to win
the rook and then to Checkmate the white
king we have came to C4 Queen captures
an E4 with checking to C3 and now it's
time to bring the black king into the
game King to D7 with Rook to B4
attacking the queen and queen to E1 with
check King to B3 Queen to C6 and now
Rook to D4 we have King to C5 and now
Rook to d8 with Queen to G3 with check
King to C2 and now Queen to G6 with
check we have King to D1 uh you can't uh
directly connect with the Rook um you
know you would like to give a check and
connect with the Rook but you know those
are weird arrows uh King to C4 so it's
better to go for checkmate uh Rook to
see it with check and now King to D3
threatening mate in one so of course
King to C1 and now Queen to G4 attacking
the rook and a few more checks can be
given but here Rook the city was playing
frog played Queen to A4 and it was in
this position and move 78 that
arjunergesi resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
it's a it's a very well known
checkmating pattern uh once you make a
move doesn't really matter what move
let's say Rook to D2 it then comes King
to C3 and once another check is given
let's say Rook to D3 with check you you
have to try something you know uh but it
doesn't work
um you you are hoping for stalemate it's
just gonna never happen like captures
and now after King to B2 Queen to B5
with the check and you're gonna get
checkmated King C1 King to C3 and now
whatever move you make will be Checkmate
so that's uh of course why he resigned
after Queen to A4 it's uh regardless of
what you play it is Checkmate but this
was the first game of the of the quicker
Rapids of the 10 minute section games uh
and the second game Arjun Eric AC has
defeated pregnant with the black pieces
so that forces uh Blitz tie breaks and
now we are going to show you the first
game of the five minute Blitz tie break
so here again we have uh origin with
white and pregnant with black Arjun came
back from the dead and now he is ready
to fight again so now this is Blitz and
this game is absolute Madness so let's
check it out Ponte E4 Ponte E5 Knight F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to C4 with
Bishop to C5 and here I thought it was
finally gonna happen here I thought okay
there's both under incredible stress uh
here if you don't play it now you're
never gonna play it I really thought I I
was really expecting the Evans Gambit
here but on to C3 uh the main line of
the Joker piano we have Knight to F6 and
now Pawn to D3 we have Pawn to D6
castles and pawn to A6 and here uh the
main moves are Bishop to B3 Ponte A4 but
here we have Bishop to G5 not played
quite a lot but it is known to be the
sharpest line of the Joker piano so that
is what Arjun uses the five Prague we
have Bishop back day seven a standard
move in allowing B4 and D4 to come with
Tempo Ponte A4 stopping B5 and now Pawn
to H 6 with bishop th4 and even G5 with
Bishop to G3 and now as you've created
the outputs for your knight on F4 and H4
just Knight the E7 you want to bring the
Knight of course to G6 and then to F4 or
uh H4 depending on what arjune plays D4
striking in the center and here we have
Knight characters on e4 and we reach a
magnificent position where it seems uh
Arjun mixed up his lines because here
the position is a known one it's been
reached in a game between Ralph Mahmoud
and Fabiano corvana
uh from the uh gashima Memorial of 2016
and in that game uh Fabi uh sorry uh
played Knight captures on E5 and it's a
very tricky line where you should play
the characters Bishop captures this
attacks The Rook then comes Queen to F3
will put pressure on F7 in the Knight
and F3 uh but even uh Fabi did not play
this even uh yeah because it is it is
the strongest move instead of capturing
a Fabi just castled here and okay it's a
perfectly fine move uh Fabi ended up
winning the game uh but okay here after
Knight captures on E5 it seems that
Arjun mixed up his lines he played the
captors on E5 and it is now as a move 12
that we have a completely new game and
for good reason this is a bad move and
Prague of course punishes it he plays
Pawn to D5 now what do you do Bishop to
D3 the only reasonable move now comes
Bishop to F5 and now you can see what's
happening Queen is coming to the seven
castles Queen side and then H5 H4 and it
doesn't seem like white has an active
plan against this and the bishop here on
this diagonal is just an absolute
monster so Knights the D4 going after
the bishop here but Prague just
continues with his plan the light Square
Bishop isn't really you know a crucial
part of the attack King the H1 as
getting off of this diagonal and now
Pawn to H5 preparing Pawn to H4 so Arjun
tries spawn to H4 and Lake will even
characterize this as a desperate attempt
the defense but you have to try
something we have castles and now Queen
to E2 we have Bishop to G4 uh absolutely
crushing now F3 is impossible because
captures with a beautiful Royal Fork so
instead we have Queen to E1 and now
Knight to F5 look at this this this this
the pawns I mean The Rook here the
bishop on A7 even if you even if you
don't know how how to play chess you
realize that you know black is doing
something good here so Bishop capture is
an E4 we have D captures an E4 Queen
captures and E4 and now Bishop captures
and D for a lot of captures but all for
a very good reason C captures and G
captures on H4 now attacking the bishop
here but now Pawn to E6 a wonderful uh
it's Vision took by Arjun freeing up the
E5 Square for his Bishop but Prague
doesn't fall for it just Knight
characters and G3 with check F
characters and G3 and now Bishop
characters on E6 with G captures on H4
keeping the H file closed and now Rook H
to G8 we have Knights the C3 Arjun still
has to finish development and now Queen
captures on D4 uh Praxis I love my
position let's trade queens and let's
let's play the same game uh Arjun uh
says all right but he goes for Rook to
F4 but now Queen to D2 they're putting
pressure on that the G2 pawn and you
have to be very careful if the Knight
moves then Bishop D5 and uh well that's
all there is Queen to F3 was played uh
and this is a terrible mistake because
here proc finds Rook caps we can even do
this in slow motion Rook captures on G2
uh very nicely done of course because
the rook and F4 is undefended so here
you can and capture Knight the E4 was
played attacking the queen but now Rook
H2 check King to G1 now rooked the G8
with Chuck Knight to G5 and now Bishop
to D5 and this is now I mean look at
this it's just so beautiful to watch
um a rook the D1 was played uh trying to
trade Queens here but now it's actually
it probably didn't find it during the
game because I mean who would in this
madness I can't believe that they were
playing this well but it's actually a
force made in two if you can spot it
feel free to pause the video and try to
find a forced mating 2 for Prague while
I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
looking for excellent ways to part with
your queen and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Queen to F2
with check look at this beauty only move
Queen captures on F2 and now of course
once you free this diagonal Rook to each
one with will be Checkmate Prague did
not find this proc played Rook to each
one with check but there is no uh way to
handle this after Rook to H1 check it
was in this position unmove 31 that
Arjun ergasi resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is if you capture with the
King it's really bad now comes the
bishop captures on F3 also this comes
with the check and after Rook capture is
now Queen captures on D1 and everything
I mean you're in check you're getting
absolutely destroyed here and it doesn't
help if you capture with the queen if
you capture with the queen we can do
pretty much anything Queen characters on
D1 with check Rook to F1 and now Queen
to D4 with check with Rook to F2 and now
Bishop captures on H1 uh loses you the
queen and of course now it's completely
winning for for project it's actually a
forced Checkmate in four uh not
a lot you can do here for example after
you capture the queen let's say you play
something it doesn't really matter what
you play a very very quick Checkmate
will happen uh but yeah very nicely done
by by Prague winning this game but the
problem for Prague is that the second
game of the blitz tie breaks uh it is
Arjun who won and then he forced the
sudden death which means that they play
a three minute Blitz chess and whoever
wins the first game like if 50 games are
drawn and then one player wins the wins
the game if he wins the match Prague had
the white pieces in the first game and
Prague won that game which means that
Prague is now the uh the other
semi-finalist he will be facing Fabiano
caruana in the semi-finals Magnus
Carlsen will be facing ninjat abasov and
that means that uh well it could mean
anything it could mean that if Magnus
declines the fight in the candidates
that Prague is basically already
qualified for the candidates tournament
2024 which is absolutely incredible I've
read somewhere that he is the third
youngest player to ever qualify for the
candidates I don't know who the two
others are I mean of course number one
is Bobby Fischer and the other one I
imagine I don't know if it's Magnus
Carlsen but um
uh could be
uh no Bobby Fischer of course he is he I
believe he qualified at 16 maybe even uh
a little bit closer to the 15 uh but uh
I don't know if Magnus uh Win Mag how
old was Magnus when he qualified uh but
yeah basically the third youngest player
to ever qualify if it happened so
absolutely incredible and also there was
a really weird moment because this is
three minute Blitz chess and the Arbiter
started uh pregnant on this clock and
Prague wasn't at the board and Arjuna
was very uh visibly very upset by this
he did not want to defeat his uh good
friend uh in such a manner it probably
just came back you know he his clock was
already down to two minutes and 30
seconds on the clock he played a move
and then he slowly uh took down his
jacket he slowly set everything up you
know he slowly removed the credentials
and you know then he just started
playing and he won a very nice game
sure brilliantly done by Prague
brilliantly done by Arjun as well and
interestingly all of the games that were
won in this match were won by the black
pieces and the first game that was won
uh with white it was the one that Prague
won in the sudden death uh that uh
section uh basically decided the match
so very very interesting stuff here but
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it in this short coverage of the
quarterfinals we are going into the
semi-finals going to be really packed
who do you have uh winning do you have
uh do you have a Magnus uh meeting his
old Nemesis uh Fabiano caruana or maybe
you have something else in my maybe
Anita abaso versus a pregnant that will
be in the finals well we'll just have to
wait and see but I'm I'm very very happy
that we are you know here to enjoy such
incredible chess
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank uh City
nivas Kash up Yoon Yang Mario and tinosa
Michael shui and David Kimura for her
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the semi-finals and the finals until
this wonderful tournament ends uh thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day